now international pressure is growing on
myanmar's ruling military to stop its
deadly crackdown on pro-democracy
protesters
foreign ministers from southeast asian
countries are holding talks with the
military junta today
in an attempt to tackle the crisis
police opened fire to disperse
protesters around the country on tuesday
witnesses said security forces have
stepped up their response to
demonstrators in recent days using tear
gas and rubber bullets
the u.n says that at least 18 protesters
were killed on sunday
protesters are calling for a return to
democracy after the military seized
power
a month ago journalist dave grunabaum is
standing by with the view from kuala
lumpur so
dave just tell us about the situation in
myanmar which we know that you know well
you've covered it for many many years
foreign ministers from neighboring
countries the asean group they're
they're set to hold talks with the junta
in myanmar today
why is this meeting so controversial
yeah so opponents of this are basically
saying that
talking to the generals and any
representative of the generals is giving
legitimacy to a military government
that is illegitimate and they should not
be engaging in any conversations
with the military because they're saying
they just don't deserve it but some of
the asian foreign
by the way i should say included in that
group of people opposed to having
conversations that include
the military is a group of ousted
myanmar lawmakers who say hey you should
be talking to us but asian foreign
ministers have been saying look we have
to engage with the military that
ignoring them is not going to help us
get to a solution to this problem it's
just going to isolate them and they're
going to continue on their path
so the only way to come up with a
workable solution is to give the
military generals a seat at the table
but how much influence can they really
have on these generals
so an interesting thing you bring out
there because while western pressure
sanctions from the us really is not
going to have much impact on the
general's decision-making
myanmar the generals included value
their membership in the association of
southeast asian nations they value that
membership more than they value their
membership in the united nations
so the generals will certainly listen to
what ajin has to say
but ajin has generally been a toothless
organization
now short term the best we can hope from
ajin is that they can get the generals
to commit
to no more deadly force on the
protesters if the generals commit to
that and actually stick with it
that would be a short-term
accomplishment but long-term for aging
to help come up with some sort of
workable solution that all sides can
agree on
is going to be a huge undertaking
because right now both sides are showing
little room for compromise on their
demands
it's clear dave um that protesting is
becoming more dangerous meantime on the
ground when we look at the situation
there
amid a crackdown that's been happening
in the past days
tell us a little bit more about how that
is impacting resistance efforts
yeah so you see some of the protesters
are out there now they've got some sort
of makeshift protection some of them are
wearing construction hard hats
goggles that you can buy in a hardware
store they've got sort of makeshift
shields but
you know against live rounds i'm not
sure how much protection that's really
going to
provide which is why a lot of the
demonstrators they've written on their
arms they've written their blood type
and the contact information for their
next of kin these demonstrators
they realize how dangerous this is not
only from the number of people who died
on sunday but also they know
the junta in past years where they've
shown no hesitation to gun down hundreds
of demonstrators at a time on the
streets
but some of these demonstrators have
said if necessary they are willing to
die for this cause
because they believe if they do not
stand up to this military government now
and fight back against this coup
they believe that any hope of having a
true democracy in this country will be
lost
for at least another generation that
sense that sense of resolve is really
incredible to witness journalist dave
grunibaum joining us
with the latest on the situation in
myanmar thank you